[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
so mehr wird es nicht
177 mal heute zum letzten guten abend
die zahlen zur corona sind immer noch
feiertags geschädigt unzuverlässig ob
sie kann man nicht bauen sie wirken ein
bisschen vertrauenswürdiger weil sie
wieder in der gegend von vor weihnachten
sind das heißt aber noch lange nicht
dass sie stimmen alles weist aber darauf
hin dass die omikron variante jetzt noch
auf niedrigem niveau kräftig in fahrt
kommt das bild wird sich ändern wie wenn
einer wie ich beim 100 meter lauf
anfangs 20 meter vorsprung hätte weil
usain bolt sich hinten erstmal die
schuhe zu knotet ich würde trotzdem
nicht gewinnen und omikron ist nach 100
metern auch nicht vorbei was diese
variante drauf hat versuchen die
menschen vom fach herauszulesen aus dem
gen code des virus und aus erfahrungen
von ländern den es früher ankam als bei
uns sandra times berichtet aus südafrika
wo omikron zuerst erkannt wurde und wo
jetzt sommer ist auch das ist natürlich
einfach dort und dann sprechen wir mit
christian drosten die kurbelt lage ist
entspannt in der provinz gauteng mit
ihren metropolen johannesburg und
pretoria
hier lag das epizentrum von omikron als
es ende november los ging inzwischen
sinken die infektionszahlen
drk hat eine praxis am rande von
pretoria
die vorsitzende der südafrikanischen
ärzteverbandes und ihre kollegen ziehen
vorsichtig positive schlüsse
omikron verursacht hier in der
medizinischen grundversorgung beim
durchschnittlichen patienten viel milde
symptome als delta
meine persönliche erfahrung sieht so aus
von 110 patienten mussten nur drei bis
vier ins krankenhaus und auch sie waren
nicht sehr schwer krank
forschungsergebnisse zeigen die
wahrscheinlichkeit ins krankenhaus zu
müssen ist bei einer infektion mit
omikron um 80 prozent niedriger als bei
delta grund dafür ist laut experten
nicht nur die variante selbst die
anscheinend harmlosere verläufe
hervorruft sondern auch eine gewisse
grundimmunisierung der bevölkerung in
südafrika haben sich sehr viele menschen
in vorangegangenen wellen infiziert sie
verfügen jetzt über einen natürlichen
immunschutz hinzu kommen die impfungen
knapp 40 prozent der erwachsenen sind
vollständig geimpft und haben damit
zumindest einen gewissen schutz vor
schweren verläufen selbst die patienten
die ins krankenhaus müssen können bei
omikron auf mildere verläufe hoffen so
die forscher
sie haben die schwere verglichen ab der
aufnahme im krankenhaus
wir haben beobachtet wie viele patienten
sauerstoff brauchten auf die
intensivstation mussten oder schwer
erkrankten und wir haben 30 bis 40
prozent weniger schwere fälle bei
omikron als bei delta registriert
manch einer fragt sich deshalb um ikon
nicht auch etwas positives hat denn
während nur ein kleiner teil der
infizierten lebensbedrohlich erkrankt
wirkt die variante gleichzeitig wie ein
booster für die bevölkerung die menschen
die sich infizieren bernie quasi es
nicht nach einer infektion genauso wie
nach einer impfung aber als spezialist
für die öffentliche gesundheit denke ich
dass die infektionen möglichst vermeiden
sollten weil wir den individuellen
verlauf nicht kenne
die wissenschaftler warnen außerdem
davor die ergebnisse aus südafrika eins
zu eins auf andere länder zu übertragen
je nach altersstruktur immunität und im
situation könnten die auswirkungen von
omikron anderswo auch anders aussehen
südafrika blickt jetzt mit sorge auf die
beisetzung von erzbischof desmond tutu
am samstag tausende wollen abschied
nehmen es könnte ein super special event
werden
wir haben als menschheit in einer
hinsicht riesenglück gehabt bei dieser
pandemie beim timing die pandemie kam zu
einem zeitpunkt an dem die wissenschaft
gerade eben so weit war dass sie mit der
herausforderung fertig werden kann
speziell auch in deutschland um sahin
und smtp die gründer und
wissenschaftlichen köpfe von biontech
und in der forschung der biologe
christian drosten der seit jahrzehnten
in der erforschung genau solcher viren
weltweit an der spitze ist guten abend
professor drosten genannter klever kann
südafrika und beruhigen ja in gewisser
weise kann uns das beruhigen südafrika
ist sicherlich ein blick in eine zukunft
in eine endemische situation die sich
dort jetzt gerade einstellt nur sind wir
leider noch ein ganzes stück davon
entfernt
was unterscheidet uns von südafrika na
da muss man vielleicht auch einbeziehen
was gerade in england und in dänemark
beispielsweise passiert wo man eben
sieht was dieses virus macht in einer
winter welle das ist schon mal ein
großer unterschied was dieses virus
macht in bevölkerungen die in erster
linie geimpft sind und nicht schon
mehrmals wahrscheinlich durch infiziert
sondern eben wo die immunität jetzt
aufgebaut wird und da
haben wir im moment so ein bisschen
widersprüchliche informationen
einerseits sehen wir diesen sehr starken
anstieg der fälle dass es sehr
besorgniserregend andererseits kriegen
wir gerade aus london beispielsweise und
auch sonst aus england die information
dass eben die falsch wäre vielleicht
doch nicht so ist wie bei den viren mal
schwerer heißt also die erkrankung
richtig die die schwere der erkrankung
im moment gemessen an der zahl
derjenigen die bei infektion ins
krankenhaus müssen diese zahl scheint
geringer zu sein und ist es ja offenbar
so dass dieses virus in diesem moment
alle die menschen erreicht vor allen
dingen die noch nicht geimpft sind und
in deutschland sind unerfreulich viele
menschen verglichen beispielsweise mit
england oder den markt noch nicht
geimpft ja das ist leider ein deutsches
spezial problemen also wenn wir uns die
großen industrieländer in europa
anschauen da hat deutschland tatsächlich
die höchste quote von personen die
keinen kontakt mit dem virus hatten und
auch nicht geimpft sind und wir wissen
nicht was das für uns dann bedeutet also
selbst wenn bei geimpften wie wie sich
das abzeichnet die krankheit schwerer
doch erträglich werden sollte haben wir
eben diese große gruppe in der
bevölkerung um die man sich da sorgen
machen muss und die sicherlich auch ein
bisschen das politische handeln damit
bestimmen wird nun haben sie in den
letzten wochen gesagt dieses omikron
virus oder die variante omikron dieses
virus die könnte sich als ideales virus
herausstellen für den übergang von einer
pandemie zu einer endemischen situation
was heißt das auf deutsch
endemische situation heißt dieses virus
wird zu einem erkältungsvirus wie viele
andere auch wie übrigens vier weitere
corona wären in der vergangenheit schon
und es ist natürlich eine gute situation
wenn ein virus hat das nicht mehr so
krank macht das aber gut übertragbar ist
so dass es im prinzip alle
immunitätsrecht in der bevölkerung sucht
und findet und dort immer noch mal so
ein update der immunität hervorruft und
das wird sich dann verlagern zu den
kindern denn die sind die werden ja
immer nach geboren und sind
immunologische naiv während die
erwachsenen alle kontakt mit diesem
virus hatten und häufig daneben mit
hilfe der impfung auch diesen kontakt
haben konnten ohne dabei schwer krank zu
werden das heißt also es könnte eine
situation jetzt kommen im nächsten jahr
auf die wir so gehofft hatten in diesem
jahr wir hatten ja letztes jahr um diese
zeit gemeinsam die erwartung dass nach
dem beginn der impfungen die situation
sich normalisieren würde und niemand ich
weiß die expertin bahn immer skeptisch
aber niemand in der bevölkerung oder wir
journalisten wir haben alle nicht
glauben wollen dass wir ein jahr später
in einer ganz ähnlichen situation sind
können sie den weg zeigen der uns jetzt
in den nächsten drei vier monaten in den
situationen bringt dass wir unser
normales leben zurückbekommen na ja also
ich denke es wird in europa und auch in
deutschland so sein dass wir jetzt
vielleicht bis ostern diese situation
jeweils speziell politisch moderieren
müssen also jedes land muss schauen
welche spezial probleme ist hat wie die
infektionen verlaufen hier in
deutschland haben wir ja gerade schon
gesagt haben wir eben dieses besondere
problem der vielen ungeimpften da muss
eine lösung natürlich her und wir müssen
da sicherlich über die booster kampagne
auch gegenhalten dann wird die
temperatur wärmer werden wir kommen ins
zweite quartal dann wird es auch ein
update der impfstoffe geben und ich
denke dass jeder erwachsene sich noch
mal ein update verschaffen sollte also
noch eine weitere impfung
und dann gehen wir in den sommer und
wieder in den winter und im winter wird
sich letztendlich wirklich zeigen wenn
das virus bis dahin sich nicht sehr
stark weiter verändert werden wir
wahrscheinlich einen relativ normalen
winter haben vielleicht wie in einem
normalen schweren influenza winter wo
wir natürlich die alten und gefährdeten
nochmal mustern müssen damit die gut
über die zeit kommen während vielleicht
die normalen gesunden erwachsenen gar
keine booster impfung mehr brauchen das
ist durchaus im bereich des möglichen
und wir dann uns einigermaßen bewegen
können vielleicht muss man noch maske
tragen in bestimmten größeren
situationen in innenräumen das will ich
jetzt nicht ausschließen aber unsere
größte sorge im moment muss sein was
passiert mit den ungeimpften in der
bevölkerung gerade mit den älteren
ungeimpften wie bekommen wir das
zumindest bis zum nächsten winter hin
dass die alle geschützt sind das klingt
wie etwas was zu schaffen sein sollte
dankeschön professor thorsten und ein
gutes neues jahr ihnen auch
das interview haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt die nachrichten von gundula
beginnen jetzt mit weltpolitik die in
diesem moment noch läuft zur stunde
telefonieren us-präsident beiden und
russlands präsident putin wegen des
konflikts um die ukraine aus dem weißen
haus hieß es zuvor beiden wolle für eine
diplomatische lösung werben aber auch
die bereitschaft zu strafmassnahmen
betonen sollte russland weitere
militärische schritte im osten der
ukraine unternehmen der kreml hatte
zuvor ein neues schreiben putins an
beiden veröffentlicht in dem die
berücksichtigung der nationalen
interessen des anderen betont wird
wegen steigender corona infektionszahlen
hat die bundesregierung italien malta
und kanada ab neujahr als hochrisiko
gebiete eingestuft wer von dort einreist
und nicht vollständig geimpft oder
genesen ist muss zehn tage in quarantäne
und kann sich frühestens nach fünf tagen
frei testen in münchen hat die polizei
verbotene demonstrationen gegen die
korona politik aufgelöst tausende waren
durch die innenstadt gezogen es gab rund
700 anzeigen wegen ordnungswidrigkeiten
und etwa 20 strafanzeigen wegen
widerstands gegen die polizei
gilliam maxwell die langjährige
vertraute des verstorbenen us
multimillionär saps team ist von einem
geschworenengericht in new york der
beihilfe zum sexuellen missbrauchs
schuldig gesprochen worden die heute
60-jährige soll apps stehen über
jahrzehnte minderjährige mädchen
zugeführt haben das strafmaß wird später
verkündet und kann bis zu 40 jahre
gefängnis betragen maxwells familie und
die verteidigung wollen berufung
einlegen der österreichische ex-kanzler
sebastian kurz wird künftig für den
deutsch amerikanischen investor peter
thiel arbeiten der 35 jährige bestätigte
er werde in den usa bei thiel capital
starten einem fond des
milliardenschweren internet unternehmers
der zb den online-bezahldienst paypal
mitgründete kurz hatte sich nach
korruptionsvorwürfen die er bestreitet
aus der politik zurückgezogen
an den finanzmärkten hat die pandemie
die geschäfte auch dieses jahr
beherrscht dazu kamen
lieferschwierigkeiten und
materialengpässe und dabei haben sich
die kurse erstaunlich gut entwickelt
frank bethmann welche bilanz zieht man
an der frankfurter börse schon eine gute
ist mag sich platt anhören und ist doch
so war aktien bleiben in der krise
beliebt auch weil es kaum alternativen
gibt abzulesen am dax der am letzten
handelstag nochmals etwas zulegen konnte
20 21 steigt das deutsche
börsenbarometer insgesamt um 16 prozent
noch deutlicher das kursplus an der
technologie lastigen amerikanischen
nasdaq plus 28 prozent
technologie schlägt alles deutschlands
am wertvollsten gehandelte
börsenunternehmen 20 21 heißen sap und
siemens nicht aber im vergleich zu apple
und microsoft die mit abstand am
höchsten notierten konzerne der welt
millionenschwer 20 21 zudem ein jahr der
börsengänge fast 2.400 unternehmen
weltweit besorgten sich dieses jahr
frisches kapital
kein zufall klima und technologiewandel
stellen die unternehmen vor enorme auch
finanzielle herausforderung zudem
steigen 20 21 die preise für
lebensmittel und vor allem für energie
enorm die kaufkraft vieler menschen
sinkt empfindlich vielen dank frank
bethmann einem guten jahreswechsel und
bis nächstes jahr
vielerorts laufen die vorbereitungen für
die traditionellen silvesterkonzert
sie werden wieder ohne publikum im saal
stattfinden in dresden nach der absage
im vergangenen jahr aber überhaupt so
mutete in der semperoper die
aufzeichnung unter leitung von dirigent
christian thielemann seltsam still an
aber das festliche ambiente und die
melodien der goldenen zwanziger werden
für silvester stimmung sorgen zu sehen
im zdf morgen am silvesterabend ab 17 25
aber noch ist dieses jahr nicht ganz
vorbei wir sind hier journalistinnen im
aktuellen geschäft das ganze jahr wollen
wir vorne sein dort wo das neue passiert
aber einmal im jahr in der letzten
sendung lehnen wir uns ein bisschen
zurück wir suchen in der redaktion einen
der besten gestalter unter uns und
bitten dann wenn anderswo alle
rückblicke längst versendet sind noch um
den blick des heute journals auf das was
war in 2021 ohne anspruch auf
vollständigkeit und dieses eine mal im
jahr
emotion als information dieser auftrag
und diese bitter ereilte in diesem jahr
bei felix jochens
ist hier eigentlich der anfang und wo
das ende
das jahr 2021 in der korona klammer die
angst vor mutanten geht um die neue
realität auch im alten jahr fühlt sich
oft seltsam unwirklich an dazu kommt nun
auch noch die furcht vor einer
ansteckenden
möglicherweise viel gefährlicheren virus
mutationen aus england im januar ist
delta auf dem vormarsch großbritannien
meldet rekord infektionen zwölf monate
später hat der schrecken einen neuen
namen omikron rund um die welt dieselbe
sorge zum jahresanfang zum jahresende
oder wie es der südafrikanische forscher
im spiegel formuliert der omicron genau
untersuchte ich hoffe dass sich die
variante als schmusekatze erweist aber
ich fürchte einen monster tiger
sorgen nehmen und wege aus der pandemie
aufzeigen sollen die regierenden sie
treffen sich im akkord
zu machen erfordert mut
eröffnen der fordert klugheit insofern
ist der prozess deutlich schwieriger zu
gestalten
es war wichtig und richtig dass wir so
vorgegangen sind weil uns eben impfen
und testen noch nicht so wie jetzt zur
verfügung stand das impfen ist der weg
hinaus aus der pandemie das ist der
zuverlässigste helfer doch auch der
zuverlässigste helfer kann nur da wirken
wo er zum einsatz kommt
zunächst ist der impfstoff zu knapp nach
der knappheit lassen ihn zu wenige an
sich heran trotz der bedrohung
wahrscheinlich wird am ende dieses
winters
wird ziemlich jeder in deutschland
geimpft gewesen oder gestorben sein
müssen sich diejenigen noch durch den
sich hin zu lassen das bisher nicht
gemacht haben ob das ist auch an dieser
stelle mein ganz persönlicher appell
längst nicht alle folgen diesen worten
darum ist die allgemeine impfpflicht zum
jahresanfang noch kategorisch
ausgeschlossen zum jahresende liegt sie
fast unaufhaltbar munition für die
verweigerer
[Musik]
im juli bekommt der begriff extremer
starkregen eine neue dimension
mitten in deutschland war ich die dünne
naturgewalt wo alles sicher schien chaos
mehr als 180 menschen sterben entlang
der aa entlang der erft
vom fenster war ein mann im baum der um
hilfe rief das waren aber auf also nicht
20 meter da kam keiner hin er rief die
ganze nacht um hilfe weshalb nicht mehr
lief wir trauern mit denen
ihre freunde bekannten
familienangehörige verloren haben es ist
der allerschlechteste moment hier für
wenige sekunden die alles ändern laschet
beliebtheitswerte stürzen in den keller
die union zieht er mit sich nach unten
das war ja steht für die
schwesterparteien unter keinem guten
stern schon die kandidatenkür ein
unschöner kampf um die macht der
ehrgeizige csu verliert und kann laschet
das nicht verzeihen
wenn ich so eine harte
auseinandersetzung gemacht hätte hätte
ich knapp gewonnen ich bin der antreiber
wir brauchen einfach mehr tempo und
power stärke und souveränität die müssen
wir noch ein bisschen dafür arbeiten wo
zwei sich mehr streiten als unterstützen
müssten dritte sich freuen
[Applaus]
aber dann passieren der
grünen-spitzenkandidatin ein paar fehler
zu viel über die ich mich tierisch
geärgert habe am ende ein
überraschungssieger mit dem anfangs kaum
einer gerechnet hatte die spd mit olaf
scholz die
ampel steht
es folgt eine fast freundschaftliche
übergabe der macht ohne größere
zwischenfälle
nicht überall eine
selbstverständlichkeit wie der blick
über den atlantik zeigt
am sechsten januar stimmen trump
anhänger das kapitol in washington
sie wollen verhindern dass joe biden als
neuer us präsident bestätigt wird
es bleibt ein erfolgloser versuch
der neue mann im weißen haus will vieles
anders machen als sein vorgänger im ton
in der sache national wie international
und macht sich doch auch aus dem staub
in afghanistan
[Musik]
die taliban erobern das land im sturm
zurück der westen kollektiv überrumpelt
zehntausende vor ort in kollektiver
angst längst nicht allen gelingt die
flucht auch längst nicht allen
ortskräfte
der bundespräsident sagte eben das ist
beschämend
fühlen sie sich beschämt oder schämen
sie sich als mitglied der
bundesregierung
wenn man die bilder in afghanistan sieht
sind die gefühle die dabei selber beim
ausgelöst wird alles andere als schön
in der grössten evakuierungs mission
ihrer geschichte kann die bundeswehr
mehr als 5000 menschen retten und wird
dafür
öffentlichkeitswirksam geehrt eine
selbstverständlichkeit sollte das sein
ist es aber nicht immer noch stillen
weil schwierigen verhältnis deutschlands
zu seinen streitkräften
auch international bleibt vieles
schwierig die achillesferse der eu
bleibt die migration
[Musik]
russland bleibt die größte bedrohung der
ukraine und des friedens in europa
und nord stream 2 bleibt ein rohr das
meer trend als verbindet
das 2021 auch ganz anders erzählt werden
kann hat mit den mehr oder weniger
normalen menschen zu tun
[Musik]
es gibt unendliche solidarität nach der
flutkatastrophe
weiter grenzübergreifenden einsatz für
eine gesündere welt
und diese beiden hier forschen weiter
arbeiten an angepassten corona
impfstoffen und neuen therapien gegen
krebs
angela merkel wird im dezember wieder
privatmensch die ewige kanzlerin tritt
ab aus eigenem willen
die 16 jahre als bundeskanzlerin waren
ereignisreiche und oft sehr
herausfordernde jahre sie haben mich
politisch und menschlich gefordert und
zugleich haben sie mich immer auch
erfüllt
zum abschied ein gewünschter widerspruch
militärmusiker spielen ausgerechnet nina
hagen du hast den farbfilm vergessen die
heimliche an die hymne der ddr
[Musik]
für die neuen hat die arbeit längst
begonnen und zu tun gibt es vier am ende
des zweiten pandemie jahres steht der
anfang des dritten
und sicher ist die alte realität auch im
neuen jahr 22 wird sich oft seltsam
unwirklich anfühlen bis wir hoffentlich
am ende des pandemie tunnels endlich
endlich wieder ins licht treten
[Musik]
das prinzip hoffnung und jetzt wäre
eigentlich der punkt erreicht an dem
diese sendung zu ende gehen könnte
würden auf dem display hier nicht zwei
positionen stehen von denen ich weiß was
das ist mir war da steht sein name dein
name steht da lieber klaus es ist
natürlich eine für uns sehr wichtige und
wenn ich ja eine sehr bewegende
nachricht dass das sie heute deine
letzte sendung ist im namen der
redaktion und viele hier im haus sowie
da draußen von herzen dank für fast 3000
sendungen
2977 großen journalistischen geist ja
in fast 20 jahren es war eine gute zeit
wieder hört ja danke danke dafür
nein es ist so wir werden dich vermissen
und ich ganz besonders
und jetzt muss ich nur sagen was du
nicht hören willst aber es muss gesagt
werden du gehst damit geht eine ära zu
ende
danke
und das ist das allerneuste gesicht der
neue leiter und moderator dieser sendung
claus kleber wir haben ihnen von der ard
abgeworben er ist visionär auf der einen
seite aber auch große realist und das
ist das was ich auf dem sessel des
heute-journals chefs haben wollte ein
mann der augenmaß hat der aber
gleichzeitig auch eine vision hat etwas
größer denken sie freude dabei und
begleitet kutlak
ausrüster präsident was kann man
erwarten von einer regierung deren
präsident die auslöschung israels
öffentlich fordert warum ist das so sehr
ihr herzenswunsch mit einem
koalitionspartner weiter zu regieren
dessen vorsitzender sie zum beispiel
öffentlich mit einem frosch im kochtopf
verglichen sie können das alles senden
was ich gesagt habe
lieber klaus du warst nicht nur einfach
unser chef und moderator du bist und
fast herz und seele dieser sendung und
dieser redaktion
unser inspirator und motivator
wir werden dich verdammt vermisst
[Musik]
si
denn heute so nagel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer einen film von claudia augusta zum
abschied geschenkt bekommt der hat
wirklich geschafft ein bisschen ernst
muss es noch werden wird sich jeden tag
einen reim auf die nachrichten macht er
kann nicht anders als mit sorgen nach
vorne schauen
die pandemie lässt viel leid zurück aber
die wird vorübergehen anderes nicht was
an der ukrainischen grenze passiert und
im baltikum irgendwann passieren könnte
die harte linie von china die demontage
der demokratie in amerika die sich immer
weiter frisst und die europäische idee
die ihren schwung verloren hat wie auch
manches bei uns das müsste alles nicht
sein wir menschen haben das wissen die
technik die historische erfahrung um das
alles zu meister zum ersten mal sind
unsere werkzeuge so mächtig wie unsere
probleme das kann was werden
aber ohne eine engagierte informierte
öffentlichkeit wird es nichts und
deshalb muss das redaktion geben wie die
menschen hinter dieser sendung
leidenschaftliche profis die jeden
morgen antreten können mit dem einzigen
ziel die bestmögliche sendung zu machen
furchtlos ohne quotendruck und
abgeschirmt gegen politischer
strippenzieher ein tolles team und das
ist da aber das nützt nichts wenn wir
sie nicht überzeugen können dass hier
ist alles ein bisschen video zirkus wenn
sie sich nicht die zeit und die mühen
sich mit unserer arbeit zu beschäftigen
engagiert und kritisch mit dem vertrauen
dass wir uns hier jeden tag verdienen
müssen
abend zu ändern sich die nasen die hier
vorne stehen jetzt zum beispiel gundula
bleibt gott sei dank ich gehe christian
sievers kommt alles gut
und die prophezeiung dass dieser
zeitpunkt kommen würde stand ja schon
vor jahren an einem kino in berlin dass
eine unserer dokus auf die große
leinwand brachte sehen sie gleich gut
night and good luck
ein gutes neues jahr vor allem vielen
dank allen hier bis bald
[Musik]
schon gehabt schon herzlich willkommen
zum wetter das jahr 2021 ist ja fast
vorbei und lässt sich mit den jahren
zuvor vergleichen auf unserer grafik
sehen wir das ja hier als relativ kurzer
biken im vergleich zu den jahren zuvor
es war also nicht ganz so warm dennoch
ist der temperaturanstieg in deutschland
weiterhin fortschreitend denn wir sehen
uns hier im trend die schwarze linie
temperatur steigt weiter an und
begünstigt extremwetterereignisse wie
zum beispiel die überflutung im aartal
in diesem juli schauen aufs wetter
unterzieht über den ordnern tief durch
das bringt viele wolken regen und wind
aus südwestlichen richtungen kann es
stürmisch werden im süden ist es eher
ruhiger dort aber temperaturen bis minus
1 grad am alpenrand nach westen hin 12
grad mild morgen tagesverlauf ziehen die
wolken weiterhin über den norden regnet
auch unter wind ist vor allem an der
nordsee kräftig aus südwestlichen
richtungen teils stürmisch ja und im
süden weiterhin ruhig und teilweise
sonnenschein zumindest dort wo es keinen
nebel gibt temperaturen dazu mit
höchsten werten von teils zehn grad im
süden sonst sehr mild im westen 15 grad
oder 16 im südwesten ja und die nächsten
tage gehen überwiegend mild weiter neuer
ist es trocken bis 14 grad und am
sonntag dann neuer regen im norden sowie
am montag und damit ein schöner amt